five years ago a little animation show
about a high school volleyball team went
on air it wasn't too long before it
became a worldwide fan favorite winning
over not just the Shonan and Sports
anime buffs but many others too that
little show haikyuu
is now three seasons and 60 episodes old
and will be back soon with a highly
anticipated fourth season Sbrocco dates
first the story of high cube inspired by
the player once called the Little Giant
in an to show yo joins karasuno high
school and it's volleyball club Hinata
is tiny for a sport that considers
height its biggest weapon but he's
determined not to let that get in the
way of his dream of emulating his idol
he meets his match in the taciturn carga
Yamato Bo who unlike him is a natural
talent and was once a rival hit sworn to
surpass teammates now but still polar
opposites the freak duo must learn to
work together not just for themselves
but because they may be their team's
only chance to get back to winning ways
the anime chronicles Kara sunos journey
from a foreign power house to gritty
underdogs and eventual giant killers
it's a simple narrative one we've seen
play out in plenty of sports anime and
other anime for that matter - so what is
it that makes haikyuu special because
special it is the anime ranked 23rd on
NHK is best 100 anime in 2017 it's been
voted one of the top anime shows
guaranteed to make you happy and the
sales of the manga have also remained
consistently high so today let's try and
unravel the appeal of haikyuu and why
you should watch the series preferably
before season 4 airs
[Music]
there's no obvious reason that makes
haikyuu stand out amongst its
counterparts when it has and this is
probably its biggest draw are subtle
ways in which it does things differently
this isn't just in its character design
and storytelling but also its humor use
of emotions and the role volleyball
plays in the show volleyball is
intrinsic to haikyuu it's not just a
passing theme to start the story off and
get back to every once in a while it's
not there simply as decoration to make
the players look cool in their uniforms
well as they make unbelievable shots one
thing I feel haikyuu does really well
compared to other sports anime is that
it actually teaches you a lot of things
about volleyball there are lessons
embedded everywhere on what constitutes
a block or a service ace on the
functions and positions of each player
on the court it gets more complicated as
you learn the technicalities behind the
many ways Spikers make contact with the
ball or how long a pinch server can
remain on court it has this cleverly
through little cartoon diagrams in the
form of dialogue between characters and
through slow-motion replays just like in
real sports programs so it never really
feels boring or convoluted if that's the
case you're probably thinking why you
should watch an anime about volleyball
when you can simply just watch the real
game on TV right wrong because while
volleyball remains at the heart of the
series it never eclipses the other more
important aspects
shut up
it's coming over
such as it's wonderfully endearing cast
of characters one of high Q's biggest
strengths is its character design no two
characters are alike not in the way they
look or even their personalities you
have the clumsy but intensely
competitive Hinata the genius car guy
armor with godly skills who sucks at
making simple conversation and the
goateed are zoom on it Asahi who looks
like a gangster but is really just a big
softy within a short span of three
seasons
haikus managed to fully flesh out the
characters each with their own distinct
quirks attitudes ambitions and motives
this doesn't just go for the boys of
karasuno but the numerous rivals friends
and mentors they meet along the way many
of these characters have their own
personal connections and equations that
have nothing to do with the others or
the story's main plot but still add to
your viewing experience some of them
have relevant backstories but those who
don't aren't any poorer for it
now I've heard many anime fans say that
a series loses out when it doesn't have
character development and progression if
this were true and indeed it makes sense
anime series with a relatively shorter
runtime are at a distinct disadvantage
over their longer running rivals in the
case of haikyuu the story told so far
makes up less than a year in the lives
of its characters short of uprooting the
story from reality and taking it into
unknown in Supernatural territory it's
impossible to expect high Q's characters
to show a great deal of development and
progression but that's not to say they
don't change and grow they do but in
small important ways perhaps the best
example of this is the transformation of
tsukiyojima you first see him as a
player who has potential but is held
back by his aloofness and his disdain of
those who try to hard call collecting
and caustic tongued he never passes up
an opportunity to dis sonata in car
gamma for being slaves to their passion
but as the story progresses suki chimas
masks of indifference start slipping
just a little at a time until we see him
for what he truly is an intelligent
thinking player capable of turning any
match around with a love for the game
that's second to none that a character
seemingly on the sidelines suddenly
turns into the hero of season threes
both unexpected and sweetly satisfying
that's what high Q does best it
surprises you in little doses and that's
all it takes to make its characters
endearing and memorable
while on the subject of characters can
be remiss not to talk about high Q's art
style its hurry to food or Dante's
illustrations that make the characters
pop with life and grab your attention
to a great extent the focus is on the
facial features distinct eyes pointy
chins a lot of crazy hair all drawn with
sharp pencil lines if perhaps Peaks a
fuller Dante's admiration of bleach
created tight Deku bow another artist
with a drawing style all his own and
very different from others what you'll
get are characters with faces that
express a myriad of emotions with his
cast of teenage boys the artist could be
forgiven for getting a little lazy here
and there but that doesn't happen even
the minor characters have been drawn
with some amount of detail you
definitely won't find same face syndrome
here the mangaka also has fun with the
illustrations take the case of bokuto
Kotaro the silver head Ace of bucura
Donny high school's volleyball team who
strangely resembles a great horned owl
why is this relevant you asked because
foo Kuro in Japanese means owl you get
that then there's the way the mangaka
draws karma with an exaggerated crown
and cloak each time someone calls him
king of the court a hated nickname from
middle school that's a testament not to
the players caliber for his image as an
unapproachable monarch who terrorized
his teammates
the arts at its best in the action
sequences as is with most sports or
battle anime fluid lines and beautiful
proportions bring the players and the
game to life as a player stretches his
body to its limits to make an impossible
save the artwork heat right up in some
sequences like when a fearsome rival
delivers a punishing smackdown the
drawing is more manga light to make the
moment more impactful we've seen the
quality of the art dropping quite a few
anime but this hasn't happened in high Q
hopefully it never will if clever
character design and a strong art style
do a lot of the talking in high Q the
storytelling does the rest PI Q is at
its core a simple tale of a bunch of
high schoolers working towards their
dreams of volleyball greatness it could
mean beating stronger teams to get to
the Nationals it could even be a more
personal goal like besting arrival you
look up to in the game there are no
grand and lofty ideas yet it's in its
simplicity that high Q shines its
brightest
rather than taking the viewer on an
emotional roller coaster
the mangaka uses small moments that
leave nuts impressions one such moment
is the fight between Hinata and Kageyama
that comes after the spike it expresses
its wish to try out a new form of attack
with barely any time left for the next
tournament it's not unusual to see the
two squabble they're always at each
other's throats but you know this is the
first disagreement that might just break
their fragile partnership the writer
cleverly uses a bystander with the timid
Agha cheeky toka to drive this point
home as the quarrel intensifies joshi
begs the two boys to be friends again
but the viewer is the only one listening
to her please
one of my favorite pieces of writing in
high q-- is the silent dinner at the end
of the first season karasuno have just
lost a big match after coming within
touching distance of victory sitting
around a table full of food
the boys dig in without a sound eating
like there's no tomorrow
you've seen them eat a hearty meal after
a hard-fought game many times before but
this time as their tears flow freely in
between mouthfuls of food and their
muffled sob speak volumes you can't help
but feel their heartbreak and share
their sorrow between these smartly
written scenes the story progresses at a
brisk pace with few dull moments yet it
also knows when to take its time around
certain situations the perfect example
of this is in season 3 where a single
match stretches into all 10 episodes but
never once feels like the drag the
writing doesn't falter even in the
lighter moments keeping the momentum
going with humor and fun banter there
are tiny gems of humor in the most
unexpected places - such as the Zoe's ng
high school teams banner that sports the
slogan simplicity and fortitude
that's wrong with that except that the
boys are Zoe's ng are among the
flashiest of most free-spirited with a
playing style to match these little
tricks and treats are what make hike use
writing worthy of praise
if you've read the Haiku manga you've
seen the mangakas message on page two of
volume one crude are they says the idea
behind high q-- is to create a story
with fun and great characters
we'll have you rooting for them even if
you don't know a thing about volleyball
when I say mission accomplished high q--
sucks you into a story and makes you
stay invested in his characters there
are big expectations of season 4 is
Hinata and the boys head to Tokyo for
the Nationals
it's my number one pick for anime shows
coming to us in January you can check
out my video of the top 10 most
anticipated winter 2020 anime on this
channel and that's it for today's video
I hope you're thinking about watching
haikyuu if you haven't already drop me a
like if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe to Vinnie tube for more anime
content I'll see you again soon
[Music]